okay so this is happening this is real
this is all over the internet hey guess
what we're gonna talk about this so
after Disney bought the rights to Star
Wars and LucasArts and all that good
[ __ ] they've been looking for a director
for Star Wars Episode seven and everyone
has been in the running for this Joss
Whedon Ben Affleck at one point JJ
Abrams name was thrown around a few
times he's like I'm not doing that I
have no plans to do that guess what JJ
Abrams is directing Star Wars Episode
seven that [ __ ] is official this is one
of those things you hear about and you
check the date you're like okay it's not
April Fool's Day so this is real no one
has any reason or need to [ __ ] with
anyone's head this is this is truth and
it's mind-blowing and crazy and awesome
my brain is going in a hundred different
directions right now Abrams is a great
choice Justin proof is in the pudding
Star Trek was dead then JJ Abrams gave
it CPR and now everyone gives a [ __ ]
about Star Trek again so now we have
Star Wars and let's face it Star Wars
isn't what it used to be who do we get
to reboot this the guy who rebooted Star
Trek which is funny cuz Star Trek and
Star Wars when I was growing up there
were like bitter rivals who were like
you know Spock in Star Wars people like
I'm that Star Trek now people can throw
out the thing like well you know same
director and just really infuriate old
school fans I love that [ __ ] I can say
that because I'm an old school fan I had
my Star Wars VHS as I watched them every
day right next to my Star Trek
mint-in-package action figures that I
actually still have that's real now that
we have a director I want to know who's
writing the script for the new Star Wars
movie that would be good to know JJ
Abrams is great but if the scripts
written by Michael Bay or some [ __ ] I'm
gonna I'm gonna pull back a little bit
and go let's reevaluate this situation
what you really have to think about is
Star Trek Star Trek into darkness is
coming out that's the second new Star
Trek movie I imagine the plan wasn't to
reboot Star Trek and just have two
movies but the time frame is the new
Star Wars movies gonna come out in 2015
this makes me really think and put my
chips on well JJ Abrams is probably not
gonna direct a third Star Trek movie
which makes me pull back and go okay
well that's great for Star Wars but Star
Trek might take a hit we saw what
happened with the third x-men movie when
singer left I think he's a great choice
and I imagine the thing that's going
through his mind is when he made Star
Trek he wasn't a big Star Trek fan he
just wanted to make a cool movie that
movie lovers would like happens to be
Star Trek but Star Wars he's a huge fan
of so he's got to be feeling that
pressure a bit more you know he's like
these are characters I love I hope his
love for Star Wars doesn't compromise it
shouldn't but is something you got to
think about that is the world we live in
those are my priorities right there the
getting sworn in in his second
inauguration who gives a [ __ ] I'm not
doing a video on that [ __ ] JJ Abrams
directed a new Star Wars movie give me
my camera I'm talking about that [ __ ]
right now man the priorities this guy so
JJ Abrams officially directing the new
Star Wars movie star wars episode 7 I
think this is fantastic news what do you
think about this whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]